cuando los legisladores y aquellos que formulan las políticas, cuando los ciudadanos y los contribuyentes,
estén de acuerdo en que eso es lo que se debería hacer
y en que es así como se debería gastar el dinero.
Se podría dar atención y cuidado en los primeros años de infancia
para los niños de bajos recursos y con otros problemas,
y se podría ofrecer este servicio gratis.
Podríamos sacar a chicos como Will del camino en el que están.
Otros estados lo hacen, pero nosotros no.
Podríamos ofrecer colegios especiales a nivel de secundaria
y bachillerato, y aún a nivel de preescolar y primaria,
específicamente para niños desfavorecidos y de bajos recursos y en particular
niños que han estado expuestos
al sistema de justicia juvenil.
Hay unos cuantos estados que lo hacen;
Texas no.
Hay otra cosa que se puede hacer,
bueno, hay muchas otras cosas, pero, de todo lo que diré hoy,
hay una en particular
que causa controversia.
Podemos intervenir
de manera más agresiva
en los hogares extremadamente disfuncionales,
y sacar a los niños de allí
antes de que sus madres los amenacen de muerte con un cuchillo.
Si hacemos esto,
vamos a necesitar de un lugar para llevarlos.
Aún haciendo todo esto, habrá algunos niños que quedarán al margen
y terminarán en el último capítulo antes de que la historia de asesinato empiece;
van a terminar en el sistema de justicia juvenil.
Aún si esto ocurre,
no es demasiado tarde.
Tadavía hay tiempo para rescatarlos;
si pensamos en rescatarlos
en vez de sólo castigarlos.
En el noreste, hay dos profesores, uno en Yale y el otro en Maryland,
que abrieron un colegio
que está anexada a una prisión juvenil.
Los chicos son presos pero van al colegio de ocho
de la mañana a cuatro de la tarde.
Fue un reto a nivel logístico.
Tuvieron que contratar maestros
que quisieran enseñar dentro de una prisión; tuvieron que establecer un límite muy claro
entre la gente que trabaja en el colegio y las autoridades de la prisión.
Pero lo más difícil fue que tuvieron que inventar un currículo nuevo pues,
¿saben qué?
la gente no llega y sale de la cárcel por semestres.
Pero aún así, hicieron todo esto.
¿Qué tienen en común todas estas cosas?
Lo que tienen en común es que cuestan dinero.
Algunos de ustedes han vivido lo suficiente para acordarse
del comercial del tipo del filtro de aceite.
Decía, "Puede pagarme ahora
o puede pagarme después".
Lo que hacemos
en el sistema de pena capital
es que pagamos después.
Pero el problema es que
por cada 15 000 dólares que gastamos al intervenir
en la vida de niños desprotegidos y de bajos recursos
en esos primeros capítulos,
ahorramos 80 000 dólares en costos relacionados con el crimen más adelante.
Aún si no están de acuerdo
en que es una obligación moral que lo hagamos,
tiene sentido desde un punto de vista económico.
Quisiera contarles acerca de la última conversación que tuve con Will.
Fue el día de su ejecución.
y estábamos ahí hablando.
Ya no se podía hacer nada
en su caso.
Hablábamos de su vida.
Primero me habló de su padre, a quien conoció muy poco
y que ya había muerto.
Luego, habló de su madre,
a quien sí conoció
y que todavía vive.
Le pregunté,
"Conozco tu historia.
Leí los documentos.
Sé que trató de matarte".
Le pregunté, "Pero siempre me pregunté si de verdad
recuerdas eso".
Luego le dije, Yo no recuerdo nada
de cuando tenía cinco años.
Tal vez recuerdes que alguien te lo haya contado".
Me miró y se inclinó hacia adelante
y dijo, "Profesor", me conoció durante 12 años y aún me llamaba Profesor.
Dijo, "Profesor, no quiero ser irrespetuoso,
pero cuando su mamá
coge un cuchillo que se ve más grande que usted,
y lo persigue por toda la casa gritando que lo va a matar,
y usted tiene que encerrarse en el baño y recostarse en la puerta
y gritar pidiéndo ayuda hasta que la policía llegue",
me miró y luego dijo,
"eso es algo que no se olvida nunca".
Espero que haya una cosa que ustedes no olviden:
Entre el momento en que llegaron esta mañana y la pausa del almuerzo
habrá cuatro homicidios
en los Estados Unidos.
Vamos a invertir una gran cantidad de recursos sociales para castigar a la gente que
comete esos crímenes, y eso está bien, pues hay que castigar
a aquellos que hacen cosas malas.
Sin embargo, tres de esos crímenes podrían prevenirse.
Si vemos el panorama desde una perspectiva más amplia
y prestamos atención a los primeros capítulos,
nunca vamos a escribir la primera oración
que empieza la historia de la pena de muerte.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)